madame la Première ministre 19
bombardements et plusieurs centaines de
victimes civiles en Egypte exécutées par
le régime d'alstis voilà le bilan de
l'opération française Siri très loin des
objectifs de lutte contre le terrorisme
qui était invoqué à l'origine et vous le
saviez des notes du renseignement
militaire le prouvent d'ailleurs le
classement secret défense de ces notes
est-il légitime il vise uniquement à
faire obstacle à la manifestation de la
vérité la complicité de la France dans
ses crimes il est donc contraire à
l'instruction générale sur la protection
de la Défense nationale il aurait fallu
cesser immédiatement cette coopération
et dénoncer son détournement fait par
l'Égypte mais qu'avez-vous fait
porter plainte contre le média disclose
et la journaliste Ariane ladrieu qui ont
révélé ce scandale
quelles conséquences 40 heures de garde
à vue pour la journaliste et une
perquisition dans le seul but de
débusquer ses sources ce sont les
principes fondateurs de notre République
de dans d'autres démocratie que vous
bafouez complicité des Grimes d'un
régime dictatorial
usage illégitime du secret défense
atteinte à la liberté de la presse
madame la Première ministre il est
urgent que c'est cette dérive
autoritaire
madame la Première ministre allez-vous
retirer la plainte du ministère des
armées allez-vous garantir le secret des
sources des journalistes allez vous
cesser la persécution d'Ariane lavrieux
allez vous lever le secret défense sur
l'opération Cirelli allez-vous condamner
les crimes du général altissi allez-vous
cesser enfin de vendre des armes qui
servent quotidiennement à réprimer le
peuple égyptien
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur Éric Dupond-Moretti ministre de
la Justice et garde des sceaux
merci merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député ne vous en déplaise
la justice de notre pays est totalement
indépendante
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre ce n'est pas une
réponse je ne vous ai pas interrogé sur
l'action de la justice je vous ai
interrogé sur la plainte que le
gouvernement a déposé je vous ai sur le
choix que le gouvernement a fait de
classer secret défense des notes de la
Direction du renseignement militaire qui
ne vise qu'à une chose cacher la
culpabilité de la France mais alors dans
des actions
merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre de la Justice
[Applaudissements]
ne vous en déplaise monsieur le député
lorsque l'action publique est en marche
et bien la justice doit faire son
travail et si la justice estime que
cette plante ne doit pas prospérer elle
le dira et si elle estime le contraire
elle le dira également en toute
indépendance une fois encore une fois
encore une fois encore une fois encore
mais c'est ma réponse ne vous en déplaît
[Musique]
paroles
vous êtes libre de vos questions le
gouvernement est libre de ses réponses